Here’s another real world data set, this is the
Space Shuttle Challenger and some of you
might remember on January 28, 1986, it
exploded and was destroyed and seven
astronauts on board passed away. So,
this example of would be one where the
question is whether a good set
decision, could have predicted this disaster
and saved the lives of the astronauts on board.
On the day of this tragic launch, the
temperature was unusually low, at 36
degrees Fahrenheit. So, the NASA
engineers asked themselves, do we
have data from past flights to see if this
temperature could cause problems.
They graphed the temperature Xi versus
the number of O-rings that had failed
in the past, because those were
known to be affected by temperature.
In seven flights there were failures; in
fact, sometimes they failed twice and
sometimes only one of them failed.
And the temperatures were all over
the map, 70, 57, 63, 70, 53, 75 and 58.
Now, these were all the cases where
a problem occurred and the question
was, would the lower temperature
increase the chances of a problem
occurring? Now, as a good statistician,
what do we do? Linear regression?
Do we compute confidence intervals?
Or do we find a maximum likelihood
estimator. Check exactly one
box of the most appropriate term.